okay leute herzlich willkommen zu einem
kleinen mini blog ich weiß nicht ob das
jemals youtube erreichen wird es ist
jetzt 22 30h samstag dem 16 juli und ich
hatte mit wenig abgesprochen dass ich
eigentlich heute noch nach wien fahren
so jetzt ist es aber schon elf und ich
habe aber irgendwie diese schnapsidee
dass ich unbedingt heute abend fahren
muss ich will unbedingt ich will hier
raus jetzt hat meine hausarbeit
abgegeben und will jetzt einfach hier
raus ist die studentin steht bilden
youtuber steht rein und wir wenigen wien
besuchen
deswegen liebe leute ja herzlich
willkommen zum schnaps sie den blog
deshalb nachts wir fahren jetzt sechs
stunden nach wien
ok diesen gentlemen wir sind im auto
bevor wir uns aber auf die große lange
reise nach österreich ins ferne land der
berge münchen waren müssen wir erst noch
mal zu tanken und tanken
b
proviant eingeladen wir sind
ausgestattet wissen gestärkt
leute ich sage immer wenn man lange
fahrt vor sich hat da muss man fit sein
man muss so sein
man muss vor allen dingen körperlich
auch am start sein deswegen ist es
wichtig dass man sich gut ernährt
deswegen habe ich mir wie manche von
euch vielleicht schon gesehen haben
gerade eben ein bisschen geholt es ist
obst im haus man kann die vitamine
richtig schmecken
es ist jetzt ziemlich genau viertel nach
eins und mit sagen wir kommen voran
die bereiche keine ahnung was ich was
ich sagen soll diesen block war
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll wir
fahren etwa 80 die gegend welche musik
ich habe radriss khalifa rolling papers
und klassiker übrigens noch schönig
münchen durch und ich bin mal gespannt
ob ich das durchfahren kann als er sagt
mir das einfach zeit fitter nach 5 es
ist schon geil all das ist schon geil
endlich mal die hausarbeit geschafft uni
ist jetzt erstmal abgeschlossen für
dieses semester und jetzt habe ich quasi
frei die ferien für mich jetzt und ich
bald nach wien zum wen
so leute wir müssen jetzt
selbstverständlich auch noch immer nach
österreich fahren die vignette kaufen in
österreich muss man sich ja diese
schönen plastikding auf europa
deswegen sind wir hier an der raststätte
keine ahnung geschaut
einmal das hier und heute kriegt ihr mit
was hier abgeht aber wir sind ein
bisschen quasi ohne aufhaltsame wären
jetzt so gesund wie wir nicht nur
bereichen würste geben sondern jetzt
eine absolute ballaststoffreiche
ernährung übrigen eschau daran die frau
hier in saana sommerberg süder woche nur
wir sind in timbuktu beste
autobahnraststätten verkäufe aller
zeiten möglich dass geben es ist zwei
uhr nachts in die frau war so freundlich
und hat mich sogar daran erinnert dass
wir abschalten müssen
franken also noch einmal rückwärts nach
hinten tanken
gott ist immer so peinlichen rastatt nur
so flogen alle starren ein anderes so
schlimm alle man könnte mit dem
maschinengewehr in der hand reihen
laufen leute würde ein weniger an staub
dallas
entschuldigen kleinen plausch gehalten
mit den leuten die kamen aus stade sind
auf einer kirchenfreizeit auf dem weg
nach kroatien haben auch schon zwölf
stunden autobahnfahrt hinter sich da
drüben steht den bus schöne grüße an die
kirchen freizeit aus stade
ihr seid cool drauf
sonne gentleman wir haben in salzburg
passiert haben jetzt noch 242 km vor uns
bewegen
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was die
maximale höchstgeschwindigkeit in
österreich ist ich fand's einfach mal
die leute dann machen wir lieber meine
kurze pause ich hab mich jetzt mal kurz
in the meantime 20 minuten so und dann
aber weiter 20 minuten später sind alle
ein bisschen ausgeruht wir sind alle ein
bisschen ausgeschlafen
so leute jetzt sind wir endlich da
endlich angekommen wir mittlerweile
schon 13 uhr am sonntag ich bin nämlich
gestern einfach in die kiste gefallen
mit kiste und ist hier ist warum ich
daher fallen ja ich liebe das wasser
wieder von diesem blog dank fürs
zuschauen und lasten auf jeden fall